boris johnson and rishi sunak were happy
to scan their phones to order pizza
on a visit to publicize social
distancing
but now after being contacted by test
and trace
they're being accused of attempting to
dodge self-isolation
and then performing a humiliating u-turn
after a public outcry
we did look briefly at the idea of
us taking part in uh the the pilot
scheme which
allows people to test daily but i think
it's far more important that everybody
sticks to the same rules and that's why
i'm going to be self-isolating until the
26th of july monday
the 26th of july it was a visit to 10
downing street by the health secretary
sajid javid
on friday morning that led to the pm and
chancellor being identified
as contacts of someone who tested
positive
at around 1 30 on saturday lunchtime mr
javid revealed he tested positive for
kovid
after feeling groggy on friday evening
just before 10 15 on saturday evening he
announced that a pcr test had confirmed
he was positive
at 8am on sunday number 10 announced
that the pm and chancellor had been
contacted by test and trace
and would be taking part in the daily
contact
testing pilot to allow them to continue
to work from downing street
but two and a half hours later at around
10 30
number 10 said the pm would not be
taking part in the testing pilot
and would isolate at checkers the
chancellor would also isolate
it seems the chancellor was
uncomfortable with the original decision
to sidestep self-isolation when he and
the prime minister were pinged
and it's being suggested that mr sunak
put pressure
on his downing street neighbor to back
down
whilst the test and trace pilot is
fairly restrictive
allowing only essential government
business i recognize that even the sense
that the rules aren't the same for
everyone
is wrong he tweeted to that end
i'll be self-isolating as normal and not
taking part in the pilot
opposition leaders are blaming the prime
minister
what happens when the rules apply to the
prime minister he tries to wriggle out
of them
and to pretend that he's on some pilot
scheme that exempts him so
i'm afraid yet again we see it's one
rule for them
and another rule for everybody else but
the government also faces claims that
the isolation system doesn't make sense
and there's inconsistency between having
to self-isolate even if you're testing
negative
and a double-jabbed while people without
vaccines or tests
can go to a nightclub in england from
tomorrow
i'm really worried that people will stop
using the app what you need is
consistency and message from government
u-turns just give mixed messages and
then people aren't clear where they are
i'm very clear actually as a gp
that i needed to go into self-isolation
um
that i need to set an example the
original decision by the pm and the
chancellor not to isolate however
despite their swift u-turn is likely to
be both politically damaging
and undermine public confidence in test
and trace
john craig sky news